Speaker 1: So on Sunday night, this Rolling Stone
story broke written research by Hunter Walker
incredible story outlining the degree to which
members of Congress Republican members of Congress
were actually allegedly involved in the planning
of the Jan. six protests that turned into the
Trump riots. And a lot of prominent Republicans
were named in that. We heard the name Marjorie
Taylor Greene. Lauren Boebert, Madison Cawthorn
and others. One of the names we heard was Mo
Brooks. Mo Brooks is the congressman who was
wearing body armor on January 6th. Why do you do
that unless you suspect something pretty crazy is
going to happen? Still not a question that we've
gotten answered well. Mo Brooks is doing something
that it tracks with Mo Brooks and everything we
know about him. He's sort of suggesting maybe it
was his staff that was involved in the planning of
what happened on January 6th, completely throwing
them under the bus. This is just absolutely
fantastic. Let's look at an article about this
from Business Insider. A congressman, Mo Brooks,
shifted blame onto his staff after he was accused
of helping to organize the Jan. six Capitol rally.
Mo Brooks shifted blame to his staff over his
alleged role in planning the Stop the Steal
rally to. Planners told Rolling Stone that
Congressman Brooks had been in contact with
organizers for the event. Brooks said he had
no involvement in planning it, but maybe,
maybe his staff had a role. I don't know if my
staff did. We actually have a tweet? Melanie's
a no no. Who's the Capitol Hill reporter for?
CNN tweeted. Representative Mo Brooks told me
he had no involvement in planning the Jan. six
rally, but said, I don't know if my staff did,
but if they did, I'd be proud of them
for helping to put together a rally
lawful under the First Amendment at the ellipse to
protect protest, voter fraud and election theft.
Brooks was responding to a Rolling Stone
report that, as we told you identified
him as one of the lawmakers involved in
planning the rally outside the Capitol.
Brooks spoke at the event, telling the audience to
start, quote, taking down names and kicking ass.
He wore body armor as he spoke. Slate reported
in July. Shortly afterward, as we now know,
hundreds of pro-Trump protesters stormed the
Capitol in a challenge to the certification of
Joe Biden's election victory. So why is why is
Mo Brooks doing this first question? Is this an
act of desperation by Mo Brooks throwing his
staff under the bus bus as his best defense?
It may be an act of desperation, and what this
relates to is the committee and the investigation
that's going on into January 6th. And the
article actually mentions that the news comes
as the bipartisan congressional investigation into
the events of January six heats up, with the panel
moving on Monday to pursue criminal
contempt charges against Steve Bannon,
the former Trump aide who refused to share
information about any role he may have played
that day. Two people who planned that this is we
know this from the article Monday. Two people who
planned the rally beforehand told Rolling Stone
that multiple people involved in planning the Stop
the Steal rallies communicated with members of
Congress in the run up to the January 6th event.
One of whom was Michael was was Mo Brooks. The
planners also said they'd been in communication
with Congressman Paul Gosar, Lauren Boebert,
Madison Cawthorn, Andy Biggs and Louie Gohmert.
Brooks has been identified as being involved in
the planning of the wild protest, a separate event
held on January six that sought to challenge
Biden's election victory. In a now deleted
livestream, Olly Alexander, who helped organize
it, said Brooks, along with Goza and Biggs, had
come up with the idea for the protest. So there
are so many different ways in which Mo Brooks
is being implicated here. But just do it, just do
a sniff test. Do you like just a basic gut check?
He wants us to believe that he had no idea
anything might go down. Even if his staff
were involved in planning this. He didn't know
he would be proud of it. But he didn't know,
but he just decided to wear body
armor on January six. Just in case
it doesn't pass the sniff test. You've got to just
sometimes do a gut check and say this. This is
this even is this even theoretically plausible?
And it's not, and it's not. So where are there
going to be consequences for someone like Mo
Brooks? No, probably not. Mo Brooks is in a
quite a safe seat, and it doesn't seem that his
constituents have any real interest in removing
him. In November of 2022, that continues to be
the trend where we learn more and more. And yet
there seems to be very little appetite from the
people who could actually impose consequences
on these folks to really do anything about it.
We're going to talk about that a little more. But
now let's go to another revelation regarding this
Trump riot committee. And as the as the previous
discussion mentioned, this is a committee that is
really ramping up over the last seven to 10 days
that I believe is part of why you're seeing
increased desperation from these people, including
saying, I don't know, maybe my staff was involved,
which would be fine, but it definitely wasn't me.
I had no idea, but I did wear body armor. None
of these things make any sense. The desperation,
the completely kind of unhinged nature
of the allegations that they're making
is clearly related to this committee
ramping up. Let's talk about that next.